nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir muay
pour roserson bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
dépendantiste de la Polynésie française
nouvellement élue on est ravis de vous
recevoir sur ce plateau vous êtes en
déplacement dans l'Hexagone et à Paris
quels sont d'abord les objectifs de se
déplacement
tout président nouvellement élu des
collectivités vient à Paris pour prendre
contact avec les ministères et
éventuellement le président de la
République pour voir un peu pour donner
le temps des relations qui vont être les
nôtres pendant ce mandat
[Musique]
c'est pas encore fixé mais c'est
toujours
une réponse mais son calendrier et je
pense plus chargé que le mien
si on le 30 avril et pour la première
fois vous avez les mains libres pour
diriger la Polynésie vous êtes arrivés
en force si je puis dire est-ce que du
coup vous êtes en position de force face
à l'état aujourd'hui je vois pas les
choses en matière de rapport de force
c'est vrai qu'on a aujourd'hui une
stabilité qu'on a jamais eu depuis 2004
c'est une stabilité statutaire du fait
de la majorité qui sort des des urnes à
l'issue des élections territoriales donc
on va pouvoir gouverner sereinement
pendant 5 ans et pendant 5 ans on va
également effectivement s'occuper de
l'évolution institutionnelle qu'on
souhaite voir
émerger pour la Polynésie c'est-à-dire
donc dans quel sens est-ce que vous
souhaitez clairement entamer un
processus qui aboutirait à
l'indépendance alors nous ce qu'on
demande c'est un processus
d'autodétermination évidemment nous
sommes indépendantistes tous les
Polynésiens ne sont pas indépendantistes
mais il faut que chacun puisse
s'exprimer dans un processus
d'autodétermination arbitrée par les
Nations Unies puisque nous sommes avec
la nouvelle des données réinscrit sur la
liste des territoires non autonomes à
des colonisé depuis 2013 mais vous avez
déjà la Polynésie française est un
territoire qui a déjà beaucoup de
pouvoir beaucoup d'autonomie pour vous
jusqu'où ça doit aller et à quelle
échéance j'ai fixé si vous voulez
j'étais interviewé pendant les élections
à ce sujet je pense que il faut tout de
même donner du temps au temps ça ne peut
pas se faire du jour au lendemain et je
pense que 10-15 ans c'est une c'est une
bonne c'est un bon horizon les
présidents ce qui est intéressant c'est
que précisément vous avez été élu si je
puis dire enfin votre majorité est
sortie des urnes en siège d'ailleurs pas
en bois il faut le signaler le préciser
non pas sur le fait indépendantiste et
sur le discours indépendantiste mais sur
des un discours plus social
parce que la Polynésie comme d'autres
territoires d'outre-mer ultramarins
Français souffrent de de de de la
pauvreté et d'un retard par rapport à la
métropole
oui mais je vous retournerai la question
entre guillemets les gouvernements
précédents de la même manière n'ont pas
été élus sur des programmes
clamant restant Français restent en
français ils ont été également élus sur
des programmes sociaux et économiques ce
qui nous a pas empêché de prôner pour
leurs paroisse à savoir donc le maintien
dans la République nous ce que nous
demandons c'est simplement de donner aux
Polynésiens la possibilité du choix ce
qui a sous-jacent dans ma question c'est
que si vous êtes un jour indépendant
comment ferez-vous parce que
vous viviez beaucoup sous quand même
sous perfusion si vous me permettez
l'expression de l'argent public de la
métropole c'est l'assemblée question
mais maintenant nous ce que nous disons
c'est que c'est le devoir de la France
et c'est conforme à la charte des
Nations Unies d'accompagner toutes les
tous les peuples dont elle a la charge
jusqu'à leur pleine autonomie
c'est vrai mais en même temps vous voyez
bien que l'environnement géographique
fait que le niveau de vie en cas
d'indépendance risquerait d'être moins
important que celui qu'il est
aujourd'hui en Polynésie avec en effet
des transferts substantiels de l'État
donc je rejoins la question de Yves en
réalité c'est à dire que est-ce qu'à
part il y a tue entre le développement
social que vous prenez et sur lequel
vous avez été élu et ce processus
d'indépendance et deuxième point
aujourd'hui par rapport à l'opinion des
Polynésiens est-ce que vous pensez
qu'une majorité des Polynésiens vous
suit sur cette route là et il finit je
repose la question du calendrier est-ce
que vous avez une stratégie de
conviction jusqu'à la finalité de ce que
de calendrier de votre question je pense
que cet objectif n'a rien du tout pique
vous savez la Polynésie c'est grand
comme l'Europe mais en population c'est
Montpellier on serait un milliard quatre
comme les Chinois je vous dirais c'est
très compliqué comme équation mais pour
tout le monde 300 000 habitants je pense
qu'on peut y arriver il faut se donner
le temps il faut se préparer et
contrairement à l'idée reçue je pense
que c'est fortement en cherchant
l'indépendance qu'on a à livrera à
prendre les bonnes décisions en toute
responsabilité parce qu'aujourd'hui
jusqu'à présent les gouvernements
autonomistes qui se sont succédés ils
ont eu ce réflexe de dire finalement si
on prend pas les bonnes décisions c'est
pas grave on ira voir maman voilà quand
on est indépendantiste on n'a pas se
réflexes là est-ce que vous êtes dans
une zone qui est très convoité est-ce
qu'on vous éloignant de la France vous
ne craignez pas d'attirer les velléités
d'autres pays notamment peut-être de la
Chine de la Chine des États-Unis de
l'Australie ils sont nombreux dans la
région nous ce que nous voulons c'est un
équilibre nous voulons pas échanger un
colonisateur pour un autre
nous avons été colonisés historiquement
c'est pas faire l'injure qui que ce soit
avec aujourd'hui pas de différence entre
citoyens français qu'ils soient je
dirais d'origine polynésienne ou
d'origine
les métriques socio-économiques vous
verrez qu'il y a une sacrée différence
et une espérance de vie qui n'est pas la
même il y a des conditions d'emploi
c'est à dire que là la colonisation
c'est à la fois un statut de territoire
exploité qui implique que vous ayez une
économie soit une économie coloniale en
vue d'exploitation en vue de la
réalisation d'une plus-value en
métropole et de l'autre côté une
différence de statut juridique
aujourd'hui vous reconnaître que ce
n'est plus le cas même si elle a été
historiquement juridique peut-être mais
encore ça se discute vous savez quand
les Polynésiens viennent en France et
qu'il doit faire des démarches
administratives ils doivent cocher très
souvent la case étrangée dans ces
démarches administratives donc vous
voyez bien qu'il y a une différence
ensuite
avec la Corrèze avec la Corrèze il y a
tout de même une différence c'est qu'on
a eu 196 essais nucléaires chez nous
ça fait partie de vos dossiers juste un
livre je redonne la parole c'est le
remboursement par l'état des frais
médicaux pour les maladies radio
induites à la suite de ces essais
nucléaires vous avez obtenu des
engagements déjà de l'État c'est en
discussion il y a je pense un terrain
d'entente à trouver à construire
l'ensemble moi j'ai réclamé que c'est
réflexions puissent se faire avec une
mission de Liga de l'IGF et de l'IGAS de
manière à co-construire cette solution
je suis pas dans une logique de
confrontation avec avec les tâches et
dans une logique de coopération quels
sont les retombées médicales précisément
de ces gens qui meurent tous les ans oui
mais ça je dirais que c'est quasiment
naturel mais est-ce qu'il y a une
surmortalité du à ça il y a une
sûrementalité vous avez des frais
médicaux qui ont été estimés depuis 1977
à peu près 100 milliards de France
pacifiques et qui augmente de 5
milliards tous les ans
vous allez rencontrer Géraldine aux
maladies
je vais rien lui demander de spécifique
je vais évoquer avec lui les conventions
qui lient déjà l'État à la Polynésie qui
doivent être renouvelés donc il faut
qu'on envisage le renouvellement de ces
conventions je vais effectivement
discuter avec lui de ces frais médicaux
qui ont été donc le supporter par la
Caisse de Prévoyance sociale depuis
depuis les essais nucléaires il y a
d'autres dossiers il y a ce dossier
urgent des Jeux Olympiques des épreuves
de surf des Jeux Olympiques qui doivent
se dérouler athlétique que nous allons
accueillir avec bon évidemment des
toujours des difficultés à la fois
techniques d'ordre d'acceptabilité
sociale c'est un peu les mêmes questions
qui se posent je pense ou que s'est
déroulent les jeux pourquoi
d'acceptabilité pour des questions
d'environnement
et puis mal accepté par votre population
et ne souhaite pas forcément accueillir
ces épreuves il y a une partie de la
population qui est méfiante bien
évidemment on a choisi justement un site
celui de celui de tir ou qui est un site
tout au bout de l'île c'est une espèce
de
dans le Paradis et de d'imaginer qui a
3000 personnes qui vont débarquer avec
des moyens conséquents évidemment ça
soulève des inquiétudes c'est c'est à
nous de rassurer et de donner les gages
aux populations que d'une part
l'environnement va pas être saccagé
d'autre part qu'on va pas laisser des
éléphants blancs dont on va pas savoir
que faire après les jeux et ensuite que
la population allemande pourra
participer à ce grand mouvement sportif
et ne sera pas exclus à des kilomètres à
regarder les jeux sur des étrangères que
ça soit pas populaire vous avez
rencontré Amélie ou des accastéréa la
misère elle vous a rassuré ou pas ou pas
du tout elle a pris en compte mes
questions et je pense que elles sont
sécrétions sont légitimes ce ne sont pas
les miennes ce sont celles qui nous
remontent du terrain je pense que les
Polynésiens qui sont faut quand même se
dire que le surf est né chez nous et
dans la patrie du surf de se dire qu'on
va regarder les JO sur des grands écrans
ça peut pas ça va pas le faire
oui
aujourd'hui vous espérez que ce
référendum sur l'autodétermination
et lieux à quelle échéance à peu près à
l'horizon 15 ans alors ils ont 15 ans
c'est-à-dire en 2040
vous savez si demain on posait la
question évidemment qu'une majorité de
Polynésiens je pense répondre les noms
si vous avez un gamin vous avez élevé au
Coca-Cola et au McDo toute sa vie et que
le jour de ses 18 ans vous lui dites
vous tuez pas devenir vegan et boire de
l'eau je pense que la réponse elle est
assez claire c'est un peu ça la
Polynésie française à l'avenir c'est un
peu ça aujourd'hui c'est une économie
artificielle sous perfusion vous l'avez
dit vous-même et c'est ça qu'on veut
transformer est-ce que vous avez des
discussions avec d'autres présidents de
région sur ce sujet bien sûr j'ai
beaucoup discuté avec le Gabriel Servier
avec Huguette Bello qui sont tous les
deux issus du GDR comme moi c'est une
fabrique de président collectivités le
génère visiblement je discute avec
également bien sûr monsieur Mapou donc
de nouvelles Calédonie avec la
estimez que c'est un une marche qui est
commune on a des histoires parallèles on
est dans la même région on a forcément
des liens qui sont très anciens avec le
contre le fnks et le terme maintenant on
a des contextes qui sont spécifiques
vous avez un tissu à la fois ethnique et
un tissu social et économique qui est
très différent d'un territoire à l'autre
et donc c'est des pas forcément des
copier-coller de solution et de
processus qui peuvent s'effectuer merci
merci beaucoup brotherson d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle vous êtes
président nouvellement élus de la
Polynésie française on était ravi de
vous recevoir sur ce plateau merci
d'avoir été notre invité je vous en prie
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on
va revenir quelques minutes sur cette
interview Benjamin Yves vous l'avez
entendu le souhait du président
brotherson d'être indépendant et une
échéance de 15 ans est-ce que ça vous
paraît possible
les questions qu'on a posées sont les
questions je dirais qui sont les
questions centrales c'est à dire que oui
vous avez aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un
processus qui peut s'engager mais ce
processus il y a plusieurs difficultés
il y a pas de difficulté juridique par
rapport à ce qu'on pourrait penser vous
avez dans la Constitution et bien un
principe qui est un principe qui fait
que étant donné qu'on reconnaît des
peuples d'outre-mer la possibilité de
termination est envisageable ce qui a
posé un problème avec la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et là c'est vrai que
c'est une question que j'aurais pu lui
poser que j'ai oublié c'est en
Nouvelle-Calédonie vous avez deux
catégories de citoyens vous savez si
vous vous installez vous ne pouvez pas
voter parce que il y a en effet cette
volonté et bien de maintenir de geler le
corps électoral ce qui est un peu contre
tous nos principes depuis la Révolution
et ce qui a vraiment posé problème en
revanche la marge potentielle va
l'indépendance ça c'est possible encore
faut-il encore une fois que et bien vous
ayez une capacité à vraiment apprécier
appréhender cette marge bien
l'indépendance en Nouvelle-Calédonie il
y a eu trois référendum processus étant
lui-même discutable parce qu'un seul
référendum signifie indépendance alors
qu'un référendum rejetant l'indépendance
lui n'était pas déterminant il y en a eu
trois et trois rejets de l'indépendance
de l'autre côté et là je laisserai
peut-être Yves plus développé mais il y
a la question économique
au moins vous avez le nickel les
ressources en Polynésie ne sont pas tout
à fait évidentes vous avez un territoire
extrêmement grand et par définition vous
avez un environnement géographique dont
le niveau de vie est plutôt inférieur à
celui des Polynésiens aujourd'hui
trouver une source de développement un
modèle de développement propre dans
cette région qui permettrait de
maintenir ou d'accroître le niveau de
vie bah ça reste une gageur
oui je pense que c'est vous savez le
sujet c'est quand même un sujet très
important finalement c'est sur
l'influence de la France dans le monde
et notamment l'influence de la France
dans cette zone Indo-Pacifique vous êtes
au milieu de géant que sont la Chine les
États-Unis l'Australie d'une certaine
façon et on l'a vu à l'occasion de la
vente justement de d'armement à
l'Australie où on a été doublé par les
Américains et les Britanniques donc
c'est aussi une question d'influence
parce que c'est il faut pas l'oublier
c'est la zone maritime économique
exclusive la plus importante que compte
la France donc c'est c'est pas rien
c'est c'est beaucoup plus important que
ce que ne laisse près présager le fait
qu'il y ait 300000 habitants on va dire
sans être désobligeant sur un caillou et
comme vous le disiez ça attire
évidemment les conventions what is et de
Pékin et de Washington dans un endroit
stratégique extrêmement important pour
l'avenir et avec en effet un espace
maritime qui est un espace maritime qui
l'est tout autant donc au-delà des
ressources du territoire là on efface un
enjeu qui va être un enjeu du 21e siècle
et c'est vrai que le désintérêt relatif
je parle pas de nous mais le désintérêt
relatif dans lequel ce qui s'est passé
il y a quelques semaines a été perçu en
métropole et quand même très dommageable
très problématique et très
caractéristique d'une forme de je dirais
d'indolence là dessus des Français
vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis du sort du pays
et c'est pour ça que c'est important
d'en parler ce matin exactement
[Musique]